the biggest problem with our society  right now is hypocrisy all we do is  deploy judgment on others while we're  doing something else that's wrong I hope  I instill that into my daughter that you  know don't be don't judge other women  don't judge anybody don't judge anybody  exactly right now on judgment I am sure  of the following statement every person  I've ever seen in society has done  things that they're not proud of thus I  don't have the capability of judging  somebody else's life I don't know what's  going on in their bedroom in their house  in their head in their relationship I  just hate judge I'm crippled by judgment  I want to eliminate it